this this is great for low wages can you
tie things because eighty percent of the
students graduate and can't speak
english project right and you're out of
everybody is okay no my view okay in our
system we put a lot of emphasis on
counting the number of words you know
and and my belief is that the more words
you know know in the sense of being able
to recognize people get all hung up
about passive vocabulary active
vocabulary pass it is good because the
big thing is to understand and if you
have a big passive academy eventually
you start to use those words if you have
the opportunity to use them I think our
system has all kinds of application for
English speakers to improve their own
level of literacy so we can go out and
whatever yeah I think open up I think so
but they gotta be motivating like
someone who's learning a foreign
language is going to be motivated to
learn that foreign language yeah I
believe I would love to see our system
you know it used but how do you convince
someone that these English is not very
good and that they're important you
should be saving these words and phrases
and trying to use these more maybe a
little more accurate or different words
instead of just the same ones all the
time I think if you could get them
motivated that I think the system would
do the job definitely but your argument
is the assistant motivates our system
you need I think we help keep you
motivated but it's not enough yeah a lot
of RP learners are very motivated by a
little scores and sometimes I have a
little [ __ ] they'll say how come this
something you know and I guess instead
of being 30 1560 words it's 30 1532 so
they they watch it very carefully but
they're already motivated like there has
to be that motivation I want to learn
this language or I want to have a bigger
have you Larry in English yeah i know i
think that you know Mark you can you can
chime in here I mean we can do all kinds
of things and we have other ideas as
well about the score it introduces it
something that is motivated the score
but I still think you need that initial
motivation to actually take the time to
learn to get used to it because actually
once you get into it it is it is fun and
but I don't think that if the person is
initially motivated to do it especially
at the beginning especially the first
two weeks to build up the habit you know
I'm doing it to get yourself you getting
ready to get that momentum up to see
some results to see some change in the
numbers see if the ideal thing for us as
a link is if the system were actually in
a classroom and we're a site there's the
number of people who are sufficiently
motivated on their own to do this is
very small okay so which is from our
perspective find a science there's
millions of people seeing it if we have
a few thousand that are motivated than
do it and instead we get people all the
time telling us this is the best thing
I've ever seen even immigrants who said
I went to this government sponsored
language school for 14 months transitive
verbs intransitive verbs are the so
frustrated didn't know what I was doing
I came to your site in four months i
speaking english and this particular guy
was a an engineer immigrant from
venezuela who then went on community
college got a degree and he's is how his
can be so people some people get it but
it's a small number but if in the
classroom say the teacher of history or
social studies whatever it's called said
i want to see your score and because we
don't think all the activity index like
we constantly track who's active and who
is an actor to me in certainly and land
and in English even if it's your own
language what's more most important is
how activated if you are active you
improve and so if you keep it a sign I
want you to maintain an activity index
on this thing up so much you have to
write this much I want to see your
vocabulary increase if you assigned it
because then I think more people with
doing number people to do it on their
own small I think my first so do I
understand you correctly you're saying
you really don't have to worry about
learning about grammar grammatical
construction with me ok sir dude the
waiting to my mind the way grabber works
I gave you the extreme case stephen
krashen and he's done all kinds of tests
which show that correction doesn't help
grammar instruction doesn't help if you
give him enough reading to do and if
it's just always a little difficult for
them not too difficult and of interest
that they would prove better that's what
he says and he's got research to back it
up I don't agree that's not good my
experience my experience esteem and
particularly with Russia one of the
reason why study Russian is because it
has a very complicated and what I found
was that when you get started if you are
met with grammar explanations at the
beginning you don't understand them you
can't remember them you can apply if you
allow yourself to be exposed to the
language then at a later date and look
at those grammar rules and they start to
make sense so I will always spend eighty
ninety percent of my time on content
listening and reading and I will still
go and review some of the ground rules
to kind of help me notice stuff so that
then when I'm next this thing and
reading oh yeah right okay and some of
this stuff just takes time you know
cases in rush you understand the theory
but trying to remember what the ending
it is and the endings are you know but
it's just too difficult so my advice is
spend eighty percent of your time on
content but it's due nevertheless spend
time reviewing drivel but don't get hung
up on driver and the other thing we
always say is you're going to get it
wrong don't expect because in this
chapter they taught you the subjunctive
therefore you'll be able to do this to
jump because you won't the subjunctive
will kick in at some point six months
later twelve months later but you'll
have the maybe you have been made aware
of it or maybe not and then you listen
to whole bunch more stuff and then
you're renewable again that you may be a
little bit more aware of it and over
time eventually it starts well I have
had it demonstrated to me it's not how I
would like to learn it first of all in
the early stages it has pictures and you
sort of have multiple choice this is a
car or playing the daughter of monkey
and then and it gets more advanced it
has these scenes you know like plays and
you're asked questions about them I
don't like to learn that way it's not
obvious to me that I'm interested in
what they have to present to me in terms
of this little skin I don't like being
asked questions there's a famous quote
by a Brazilian educator
who said nothing destroys the pleasure
of reading quite as much as being asked
if comprehension questions are being
asked to analyze the text or answer
questions which is true so I I don't
like rosetta stone my son used it for
Japanese he didn't like it alex is
fluent in Korea has try to not work
prejudice but the other advantage of
saying many of these other sites on the
Internet including ours is cost because
you can try late for free if you know
why did you walk away if you like it you
spend ten dollars and then the following
month if you don't like it you walk away
rosetta stone is whatever the thing with
rosetta stone is it's kind of it's it's
easy like it's quite easy to do you get
some success you feel good getting
itself right but you don't end up
learning very much this is the only
rosetta stone will have X amount of
words in there or any of the others just
there's only this is on yet but the
language is limit the potential content
is Memphis for the clarification for
some people the stones you're talking
about some application is supposed to
attract each other right exactly rosetta
stone is is an application on your
computer although they are now they are
working to develop some kind of or they
have an online community as well lates a
package that you buy it goes in your
computer and up applause these pictures
and you answer questions sorry it's late
this is educate